a federal jury begins its first full day
of deliberations in the trial of Mexican
drug kingpin Joaquin el chapo guzman he
pleaded not guilty to ten counts
including engaging in a criminal
enterprise drug and gun charges and
money-laundering more than 50 witnesses
described el Chapo's bloody reign as the
head of the Sinaloa cartel
Jericka Duncan is outside the federal
courthouse in Brooklyn Jericho good
morning good morning al chapo if
convicted one of the most wanted man in
the world at one point could face the
rest of his life in prison now the 61
year old came to court yesterday in a
heavily armored Caravan that's typical
since this all started more than three
months ago the jury of seven women and
five men whose identities are being kept
secret for their own safety deliberated
about three and a half hours yesterday
now in a sign of just how important this
case is for the government acting
Attorney General Matthew Whitaker
personally came by to wish the
prosecution good luck now overall this
trial at times has resembled a soap
opera convicted drug traffickers hitmen
and even out Chapo's former mistress
have testified against him in fact the
alleged drug lords personal IT guy was a
star witness providing the FBI with
crucial electronic evidence prosecutors
say they also believe al chapo engaged
in sex with underage girls now those
allegations were not revealed to the
jury but again the jury will start a
full day of deliberations than just a
few hours Gael all right Rico thank you